Hey Joe,
welcome.
Thank you.
It's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
My pleasure.
I'm Sam Harris.
Sends his regards.
Yeah.
Sam's a beautiful man.
He is.
I love that guy.
And he's one of the reasons why you're here.
Um,
so universal basic income,
this is what this is all about.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's what my campaign for president is all about.
That's uh,
an interesting,
like a focus of a campaign and very unusual and I mean four years ago you'd
never even thought that that would have a chance at all.
But this is a subject that has been gained momentum and it made a,
I made a big shift because a,
I had my friend Eddie Wong on once and he was the first person to bring it up
and my initial knee jerk reaction was get the fuck out of here.
Like universal basic income.
Just going to give people money that just going to be lazy.
Nothing's ever going to get done.
That's a terrible idea.
And then I started paying attention to the rise of AI and automation and how
many jobs are going to get taken away from.
And then once you see the actual numbers,
it's pretty staggering.
Yeah,
and that's how I got there,
Joe.
Like I spent the last seven years running an organization that I had started
called venture for America and we helped create about 3000 jobs in Detroit,
Cleveland,
Saint Louis,
Birmingham,
New Orleans,
other cities around the country,
and I saw that were pouring water into a bathtub that has a giant hole ripped in
the bottom,
and that for every five,
10 50 jobs that my entrepreneurs are going to create,
we're going to lose five 10 50,000 jobs.
It's not something that people intuitively suspect could be a real issue either.
It's,
it's one of the ones where you kind of have to let go shake people like,
hey,
look at this.
This is coming.
There's a cliff.
We're going towards this cliff it,
it's darker still.
And that,
so when I was digging into the numbers,
I found that it's not this cliff that we're heading towards.
It's actually a more of a curve that we're on.
What I've been telling people is that wearing in the third inning now where one
of the main reasons why Donald Trump won in 2016 is that we automated away 4
million manufacturing jobs that were based in Michigan,
Pennsylvania,
Ohio,
Wisconsin,
Missouri,
Iowa,
all the swing states he needed to win in the center of the country.
And a lot of that was just manufacturing work.
And if you go to a factory,
you'll see it's a giant robot arms as far as the eye can see.
So it's not just that you have artificial intelligence on the horizon,
it's that we've been eating away at the most common jobs in the u s economy,
uh,
for almost 20 years now.
And it's just now hitting a point where it's pushing more and more unskilled men
in particular out of the workforce now.
Are there other alternatives that you've considered other than just universal
basic income,
like educating people about this being a real issue and perhaps pushing them or
directing them towards other occupations?
Yeah,
so that,
that's the,
uh,
recipe that most people are attracted to.
So I just want to unpack the number is a little bit more so people have a sense
of it.
I was just with a bunch of truck drivers in Iowa last week and there's a guy at
dentist but gasky that gave me a ride from Altoona at Grinnell in Iowa where
I've been campaigning and the truth of it,
Joe,
is that there are three and a half million truck drivers in this country right
now is the most common job in 29 states and the average truckers,
a 49 year old guy with a high school education,
maybe ex military,
like Dennis was a,
they're making like $50,000 a year.
So then if you say,
Hey,
I'm going to retrain half a million truck drivers for what exactly is like issue
number one,
right.
And that these guys didn't love school 30 years ago.
It's not like driving a truck has made them really excited about the idea and
then the new job you're training them.
Before I looked into the data as to how good we were at retraining,
let's say displaced manufacturing workers in the Midwest when we started
decimating their jobs.
And we're terrible at like according to independent studies,
government funded retraining programs had a success rate of between zero and 15%
in real life.
Like this is what actually happened to the workers of Michigan and Indiana and
Ohio.
And so if you say we're going to retrain these people,
then you also have to come up with a way for us to become amazing at something
that right now we're really,
really bad at.
And if you are an employer,
which you are,
would you rather employ a 50 year old former truck driver with health problems
who got some certificate program?
What would you rather higher a 25 year old kid who went to community college is
probably cheaper,
has lower expectations,
uh,
and his skills are natively going to be a little fresher.
I mean,
if you were an employer,
you'd probably choose number two.
I agree.
Um,
but I,
I'm,
I mean I'm trying to look at this through rose colored glasses,
I guess.
Well,
thank you.
If there's a way that these people can adapt,
you know,
I mean some will for sure,
you can retrain and rescale some people,
but if you look at,
even the conversations we're having around this where people legitimately talk
about retraining coal miners to be software engineers,
stuff that on the face of it makes no sense.
But the,
the reason why we're stretching for that is because we're looking for some kind
of retraining oriented solution when the numbers show that that's just not going
to be the recipe for actual success.
And this is where,
where this whole learn to code controversies coming out online where people are
actually getting banned for writing,
learn to code.
It's a really a hot subject on Twitter and it's very confusing too.
And I haven't really gotten an explanation for why that's such an offensive
thing to say,
but people are getting banned for even analysts.
I know a show's coming around saying learn to code and it's very weird.
But the idea behind it is that it's kind of preposterous to ask someone who
doesn't have an education to do something that's as difficult as code computer
language.
Yeah.
And unfortunately we're going to get to a point where AI can do some basic
coding at a certain level.
So if you think about the impulse to say,
learn to code,
what it's really saying is you need to do something that the market values,
it's like,
Hey,
being a truck driver,
the market's not going to value that much.
And when the truck started driving themselves in the next five to 10 years,
so what does the market value?
And then people are like,
well,
coding and stem and uh,
engineering skills.
And so there's a drive to try and push people in those directions.
But if you look at the numbers,
uh,
about 8% of American jobs right now are in stem fields,
like in technology,
engineering,
math,
etc. So you're talking about 92% of the population that is not in those fields.
And it's unrealistic to expect that 92% to somehow shift into the 8%.
Right.
And they're even be places for them.
Yeah.
That that's true too.
Even if they perfectly seamlessly transitioned,
there's too many people for those jobs.
Yeah.
So I,
I've been driven to universal basic income in part because I had been looking at
the numbers.
The five most common jobs in the United States right now are administrative and
clerical work,
retail and sales,
food service and food prep,
truck driving and transportation and manufacturing.
Those five jobs comprise about half of all American jobs.
Only 32% of Americans graduate from college.
So the average Americans have high school Grad during one of these five jobs.
And if you look at it,
technology is already doing a number on each of these jobs.
Like the first administrative and clerical includes call center workers.
And Ai is in the process of taking over that job.
Retail and sales,
30% of malls are closing in the next four years.
So the,
the danger here is to think of it as artificial intelligence is coming.
It's actually already eating up the most common jobs in our economy and it's
driving Americans,
uh,
into distress in various ways.
In the numbers.
Now when you talking about universal basic income too,
there's two questions that come up.
How much money and where's it coming from?
Yeah,
so first I want to say that if you look at the heritage of universal basic
income,
it's a deeply American idea where Thomas Paine was forward at the founding of
the country and then Martin Luther King was for it.
Milton Friedman,
the godfather of conservative economists was for it.
And one state has had it in effect for 37 years where everyone in that state
gets between one and $2,000 a year.
No questions asked.
And this is Alaska.
Yeah,
it's Alaska.
And they funded with oil money.
And what I'm going around and telling people is that technology is the oil of
the 21st century.
So I know you spoke to another guest about,
hey,
how do you get,
let's say approximately $3 trillion a year to fund universal basic income?
And a great thing is that it's,
well,
the first thing is it's not actually 3 trillion.
And the reason why it's not 3 trillion is that if you look at what we're
currently doing,
we have a,
we're spending about one point 5 trillion right now on 126 welfare programs and
social security.
And so if you show up to someone's door and say,
hey,
here's a dividend of $1,000 a month,
but if you're already getting more than a thousand dollars and stuff,
we're not just going to stack it on top.
Uh,
you know,
we're gonna just gonna say you're guaranteed a thousand.
And if you're already getting more than this doesn't touch you,
you keep your current stuff.
If you're getting 700 and food stamps and whatnot,
then you can just get 300 on top.
So the 3 trillion actually shrinks a lot very fast because of the fact that
about half of Americans are already getting various,
uh,
income support from the government.
So the real price tag is closer to about one point 8 trillion.
If you say everyone who's 18 and up now for context,
the entire US economy is now 20 trillion,
5 trillion in the last 12 years.
And the federal budgets,
4 trillion.
So you're looking at one point 8 trillion.
It's a lot of money.
Uh,
but it's actually manageable.
And one of the things that I haven't heard discussed here with you is that when
you put money into people's hands,
the money doesn't disappear.
Like if I gave you 1000 bucks a month,
it probably would not make a big difference in the economy because they're just
go into your account somewhere and you know,
nothing would happen.
But we all know that right now,
most Americans are living paycheck to paycheck.
57% of Americans can't afford an unexpected $500 bill.
So you put $1,000 a month,
and then their hands,
it's gonna go right back into the economy.
They're going to spend it on food,
childcare,
car repairs had been putting off the occasional night out.
And then all of those businesses end up hiring more people.
And then we end up getting some of the money back as tax revenues.
So of the one point 8 trillion,
we're going to get back,
let's call it 400 billion in new tax receipts because everyone's going to be
spending more money.
We're going to save one to 200 billion on things like incarceration and
homelessness services and emergency room healthcare.
I was in New Hampshire,
uh,
last month and a prison guard said to me,
there's a prison guard.
He said,
we should pay people to stay out of jail because we waste so much money when
they're in jail.
Like he sees all the waste in the system.
So if you imagine a society where everyone's getting 1000 bucks a month,
that's like a,
it's a great incentive to try and stay out of jail because you know,
you stopped getting it if you wind up in jail,
uh,
and it reduces recidivism because when you come out of jail,
at least you have,
you know,
1000 bucks a month waiting for you and then you're less inclined to,
to commit a crime and head back in.
How much crime do you think you would actually prevent though,
by giving people $1,000 a month?
I mean,
think most of the people that are doing crime,
whether it's thieve thievery or assault,
they're not thinking this out.
You know,
this is,
this is just either a way of life for them either,
you know,
they're,
they've got real mental issues or a pattern of behavior that they can't break.
I really don't think that $1,000 a month it's going to fix any of that.
I was not going to fix all of it for sure.
I mean we'll still have jails.
It's not like,
you know,
silver bullet,
but at the margins would it keep like that person who's falling through the
cracks and feels like they have no place in society and maybe they,
you know,
it's like the people around them are also like,
hey,
you know,
you don't have any value until you get 1000 bucks a month.
Maybe.
Like it keeps off at the margins and everything we're talking about is at the
margins.
I mean everything is like this statistical curve and you're taking the people
who are,
let's call it like the last 10 to 20% but if you reduce our incarcerated
population by 10 to 20%,
I mean that's billions and billions of dollars.
So you,
you're saving money on a bunch of things.
We spend like a about a trillion dollars on right now,
like healthcare,
incarceration,
homelessness services and then the,
the magic is that if you have 1000 bucks a month and you're a parent,
so you feel this,
that studies have shown that your kids are healthier,
better nourished,
more likely to graduate from high school and get further education.
Mental health improves,
relationships improve,
domestic violence goes down,
hospital visits go down and your worker productivity goes up mean uh,
you're an entrepreneur and CEO.
So you know,
when you run a company you say,
I'm going to invest in my people.
I'm going to like treat them well and try and train them and give them resources
cause you know,
that'll increase your productivity as an organization and the public sector.
We have the opposite approach where like if I can just avoid spending money on
you that you know,
I'm going to somehow save money when we end up spending that money and very,
very dark,
costly counter productive ways in the backend because they wind up,
you know,
uh,
in our institutions and our institutions just spend a,
a truckload of money.
So if you look at the cost savings and the value gains and the economic growth
that actually gets you back about a trillion dollars or the 1.8,
this is like the trickle up economy cause none of the money disappears.
It goes right back into the economy.
And the way you get the last 800 billion or so is related to what we think is
happening with AI and all these advanced technologies.
Because if you look at who's going to win with AI and a self driving cars and
trucks,
the savings from robot trucks are estimated to be $168 billion a year just from
that one thing.
So the problem is that the American public is going to see very little of that
money,
uh,
because the winners are going to be the trillion dollar tech companies that are
great at does not paying a lot of taxes.
They'll move it through Ireland.
Amazon will say it didn't make any money this quarter.
No reason to pay taxes.
And so what we need to do is we need to put in a new tax that actually gets the
American public a slice of every robot,
truck mile,
Amazon transaction,
Facebook ad,
and every other industrialized country already has this tax.
It's called a value added tax.
And because our economy is so vast,
at 20 trillion of value added tax,
that even half the European level generates about 800 billion in new revenue.
And that gets you all the way there.
So this is much more achievable and affordable than most people think when they
start unpacking how the numbers work out.
So essentially it would be the biggest corporations,
the companies that gain or that have the largest revenue,
they're going to be paying most of this.
Yeah.
But they're going to get some of that money back obviously because one of the
things I say to the CEOs,
it's like if everyone in Missouri is getting 1000 bucks,
you know,
Amazon's going to see some of that because they're just going to buy more stuff.
Right.
That's true for all of the big companies.
What I say to CEOs,
and I've spoken to groups of dozens of CEOs,
what's really bad for your businesses when people don't have money to spend?
Why?
What's good for your businesses when they do?
So they're going to give up some money at the top end,
but they're just going to end up getting it back.
Uh,
when they're consumers end up spending a bit more and it's just been actually
fleshed out.
Like the real numbers are the projections of how much they're going to get back.
Yeah.
That like the,
so the Roosevelt Institute study,
this plan of everyone getting 1000 bucks a month and projected it would create 2
million new jobs,
uh,
and grow the economy by eight to 10%.
And then you can model out what that means to each business because in that
climate they're going to see a similar uptake and revenues.
Did they factor in all the jobs that are going to be lost?
So one of the things that's a misconception about universal basic income is that
a,
it's somehow we'll like facilitate job loss.
Job losses though,
was the reason for universal basic income in the first place,
right?
Yeah.
Which way in the midst of right now,
like right now,
as we're sitting here together,
the labor force participation rate in the United States is 63%,
which is the same levels as El Salvador in the Dominican Republic.
That's right now,
like,
uh,
94 million or so Americans have left the workforce over the last number of
years.
Now,
a lot of that's natural demographics,
a lot of that people in school,
but about 5 million of it is unskilled men who've gotten pushed out of the
workforce.
So,
uh,
so again,
this is not like a,
you know,
we're going to solve a problem that's coming down the pike.
Like we're actually in the middle of this problem.
So if you put 1000 bucks a month into people's hands,
that actually grows the economy and creates jobs,
uh,
because of more economic activity.
Now,
when you say a problem that's coming down the pike,
what,
what are the projections in terms of life?
The timeline?
Yes.
So,
uh,
there are a lot of the projections are actually pretty consistent with each
other,
which means they're probably right.
So,
so the,
uh,
so Bain says you're looking at between 20 and 30% of jobs subject to automation
by 2030,
which is pretty soon,
it's like 11 years from now.
Mckinsey says that 25%,
uh,
the Obama White House literally have like their last day in office,
they issued a report saying,
hey guys,
we're gonna automate away all the jobs.
And then like,
you know,
turn the lights off.
They said 83% of jobs that make less than $20 an hour will be subject to
automation by 2030.
Mit is saying the same thing.
Uh,
and so we have 11 years to try and accelerate meaningful solutions.
And this 11 years,
it's not like it all happens on 2030.
It's going to happen between now and then.
Progressively,
according to all of the major institutions that have looked at this.